this is Jocko podcasts number 140 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willick good
evening echo good evening
if you can keep your head when all about
you are losing theirs and blaming it on
you if you can trust yourself when all
men doubt you but make allowance for
their doubting too if you can wait and
not be tired by waiting or being lied
about don't deal in lies or being hated
don't give way to hating and yet don't
look too good nor talk too wise if you
can dream and not make dreams your
master if you can think and not make
thoughts your aim if you can meet
triumph and disaster and treat those two
Impostors just the same if you can bear
to hear the truth you've spoken twisted
by knaves to make a trap for fools or
watch the things you gave your life to
broken and stoop and build them up with
worn-out tools if you can make one heap
of all your winnings and risk it on one
turn of pitch-and-toss and lose and
start again at your beginnings and never
breathe a word about your loss if you
can force your heart and nerve and sinew
to serve your turn long after they are
gone and so hold on when there is
nothing in you except the will which
says to them hold on if you can talk
with crowds and keep your virtue or walk
with Kings nor lose the common touch if
neither foes nor loving friends can hurt
you if all men count with
you but none too much if you can fill
the unforgiving minute with sixty
seconds worth of distance run yours is
the earth and everything that's in it
and which is more you'll be a man my son
and that of course is the classic poem
which is called if and it's by Rudyard
Kipling and of course we have covered
some of his less I guess famous has less
famous poems on this podcast we covered
infantry columns which a lot of people
don't know the name infantry columns but
that's the the poem that talks about
boots boots boots moving up and down
yeah that one we read the young British
soldier which is about Afghanistan we
wrote we read a bit of Tommy and of
course Kipling was a incredible writer
and he talked a lot about war talked a
lot about being a man and his own son
his one son John was killed in World War
one at the Battle of Loos and these are
great poems and I recently read a poem
called the mental cases by Wilfred Owen
and when we got done with that podcast I
actually said I should have read it
again then I did and I just said I go
back to the beginning and listen to it
again but I should have actually picked
it apart a little bit because it's kind
of like what I said about Shakespeare
when we did Henry the fifth and I said
you can't get frustrated with
Shakespeare you can't think that you
just gonna read Shakespeare and just get
it it doesn't it doesn't work that way
there's more to it than that there's
more depth there there's a word you
might not know there's references that
might not be obvious
there's it's it's the same thing when
you look at poems like this there's more
to them than you can get with just like
reading it right there's there's layers
yeah it's what we're talking about so
the poem that I just read if is like I
said it's a classic it's read often it
should be read but there's and and
that's part of the reason why I didn't
cover it for a long time because I kind
of thought everyone just knew it you've
got everyone row yeah everyone knows
that everyone knows that poem everyone's
read that poem but it's actually not
true talk to a lot of people and I'd say
oh yeah looks likely if and they say
what's that so in order to sort of solve
that problem we covered on the podcast
and now people will hear this poem and
learn from it and I want to spend a
little bit of time breaking it down
because there's all kinds of important
lessons in it that are really solid
really solid guidance and then when we
understand it then I'll go back and read
it again the way it's supposed to hit
you when you know what's going on so
breaking it down a little bit there's no
and there's themes in this that we've
heard I've talked about and they're just
consistent through time so here it
starts off if you can keep your head
when all about you are losing theirs and
blaming it on you this one's pretty
self-explanatory
keep your head don't lose your temper
stifle your emotions as I want sounds
podcast and it's saying especially when
everyone else around you is not only
losing their temper but on top of that
they're blaming you mm-hmm
this is a little bit of ownership here
this is a little bit of extreme
ownership and I've talked about that
when someone blames you for something
you know what you do you say yeah you're
right it is my fault
this is what I'm gonna do to fix it mmm
you pathetic you don't say that part you
keep that to yourself
when when there's a problem and people
blame you know and you own it own it and
don't lose your temper
stifle your emotions next line
you can trust yourself when all men
doubt you but make allowance for their
doubting - there's a little dichotomy
here right so you got to be confident of
course I trust yourself that's what it
means believe in yourself even when
other people are doubting you you got to
trust that you're doing the right thing
you got to trust that you're capable and
you got to trust that you can make this
happen that's what it means to trust
yourself when all men doubt you but
there's a dichotomy here and this is so
important because that because what that
means what that one line alone could
lead to is am is gonna be hold for
confident right I'm confident hey I'm
right everyone else is wrong
you don't get it that's not what's being
said here cuz there's a but that's the
dichotomy part the but there's a
dichotomy part because while you got to
believe in yourself yes and at the same
time you also have to make allowance for
their doubts that means you have to
understand that you might have some
issues you might not be perfect you
might be wrong you might not be as smart
or as talented or as squared away as you
think you are and your idea that you
came up with might not be the best one
hmm
so yes you got to have confidence even
when people are down and you but you
kind of remember that they could be
doubting you for a good reason
you could be wrong you should always
have that in the back of your head
that's the dichotomy humble confident
but humble that's what we're talking
about next line if you can wait and not
be tired by waiting patience that's
about patience I think I've told this to
if I told the story about being on a
ship and waiting for Chow not that I can
remember okay so I was on my first
deployment as a seal on a ship in the
Navy where overseas were we're spending
a lot of time at sea and to eat food
which was I'm not gonna say it was
scarce mmm but they feed you three times
a day and and all the type of ship I was
on an amphibious ship there's a several
hundred Marines on ville
obviously there's the sailors that run
the ship their seals we're you know an
18-man seal platoon on there but
everyone's got to be fed mmm what is
child time and so if we would go line up
for chow
you get in line and the line would be
long and depending on a hungry are maybe
want to get up there a little early
anyways to make a long story short so we
get in line
and whatever for whatever reason they
got this rule that you're not allowed to
lean on the bulkhead you know the
bulkhead is in a plane I do in a plane
what is it the front part yeah that's a
fun look you know it's a wall yeah
basically on a ship or an aircraft it's
a wall to bulkhead so for whatever
reason in the Navy is standing in the
chow line you're not supposed to lean on
the bulkhead so imagine this you're
gonna be standing there for you're
standing three inches from a wall but
you're not supposed to lean on it yeah
now this isn't a three minute stand this
is half an hour this is forty minutes
waiting for the child to open up and
then serve everybody and I remember I
learned something about patience mm-hmm
because then you get these guys that you
know the people that they have a little
bit of authority and they're gonna use
it and if given the opportunity they
will abuse it they're gonna take it to
the next level so there'd be some guys
not all of them I was always my goal to
make friends with anybody that had
anything to do with feeding us on a ship
I wanted to be there bro because then
you get another couple extra chicken
nuggets you know maybe get an extra
scoop full of ravioli which is which is
which is important important yeah big
time especially when you're trying to
pack on the mass right so I tried to be
friends with all those people but some
of those guys they didn't care about
friends right they had that authority
and one of this one guy I remember he
had the authority it was he was in
charge of making sure that line was you
know maintained discipline in the line
that was his deal he had a badge of some
kind I want to say he was a
master-at-arms which is a job in the
Navy I think he this guy was actually a
master-at-arms so he had some kind of
badge right so that takes that authority
attitude up one maybe two notches
comin at you yeah so so I'm standing in
line one day and I'm leaning on the
bulkhead
am I being a little bit lazy sure I'm
telling you it's a long deployment right
I'm leaning on the bulkhead he comes
over hey
no leaning on the bulkhead you know what
I did what got off the bulkhead and I
just stood up straight didn't get mad
didn't get angry he's doing his job not
supposed to lean on the bulkhead just
normal face oh good yeah was I a broken
man was I have broken man did my did my
will break I don't think so
and what I did was I accepted I was able
to wait and and not be tired by waiting
so be patient this this the moral yeah
of that line well technically you
weren't able to eat without getting
tired cuz you leaned on the bulkhead
right you got corrected I got corrected
and then I got untied yeah yeah all
right next line or being lied about
don't deal in lies mm-hmm people are
gonna lie about you tell the truth tell
the truth about what's going on getting
caught in the web of lies not fun
no not fun and you see it happen with
people I'm trying to think you remember
you're a little kid and you'd think
you'd get away with some little web of
lies oh yeah like yeah or you see your
kids do it yeah they they tell a little
lie about something and the web just
encapsulate some but adults do that too
and you see that happen you see that
happen with in politics yeah you know I
never did this you know what I mean and
then they have video they have audio and
it's just if that person would have said
hey this is what I did this is what I
did I'm sorry is a bad mistake mmm I
throw myself to the judgment of the
people right okay fair enough yeah but
instead they make up some lie about I'm
not I've never seen that woman before in
my life
oh really we have a video of you yeah
apparently quite acquainted with this
woman yeah or whatever
so yeah don't get in the web of lies
it's not gonna help you
next line or being hated don't give way
to hating now what's interesting about
this is we actually have a name for
these people now right haters haters
right desolate that's a new word I think
there was such a thing as haters when I
was a kid there was no such thing as
haters yeah if someone that didn't like
you you wouldn't say that's persons a
hater
yeah it wasn't a thing well there's a
little added like sprinkled in element
when you say hater hater typically is
like someone that hates everybody
know someone who hates everything no
it's when there's an element of jealousy
in there that's what that's what a hater
okay so I actually nailed this then
actually so as I was thinking about this
that's kind of what I thought some
people aren't gonna like you for
whatever reason but oftentimes the
reason isn't you yeah it's actually them
right yeah yeah that's them
it's their they hate your success they
hate your happiness they hate their they
hate the fact that you've got whatever
it is that they want right that's
generating so yeah some people are going
to get you know if they're going to be
haters yeah and so the recommendation
here is don't don't don't don't give it
back to them yeah there's a you ever
heard that the opposite of love isn't
hate the opposite of love is
indifference yeah so the opposite of
hate there's indifference too right yeah
whatever
right that's sort of my recommend that
recommended course of action he's
someone that hates the fact that you're
winning I kind of feel sorry for him
right but yeah we've gotten past that I
guess yeah if you get by the emotional
part when someone's hating on you yeah
you do kind of fee I mean you can
depends on who you are I guess but you
can kind of feel sorry for them because
it's like it's kind of a lonely like
actually I think I think when I say I
feel sorry for him I think that's almost
like a little bit of it that's a little
bit of ego of mine too of like
little dig like like I feel sorry for
them right right the defense mechanism
of my own I think you don't I mean -
yeah it's kind of a it's kind of a back
it's a backhanded insult yeah you know
oh oh you know echo said this about you
you know I actually feel sorry for it
yeah it's almost like that guy's solo so
yes I think there's a little bit of ego
there from like what when I say
something like that
yeah that's my thinking differences
might maybe the better step like hey
whatever man hey some people gonna like
me some people yes I'm good with it yeah
over here there's a culture of embracing
that too you know how people will be
like hey if you're if you don't have
haters you're doing something wrong or
something like that like they'll say
that kind of thing to me you know how
you talk about how someone says hey
that's just the way I am that's my
personality
yeah to me that is brushing up but
against it right yeah you know if some
people cook some people gonna hate me
that's the way it is ii know actually
yeah let's think about at least let's
account for it a little bit let's let's
figure out you know maybe why yeah yeah
actually sometime this is kind of a
smaller deal than even warrants me
talking about it but something tells me
you're gonna do it anyway I mean in the
spirit of trying to understand the
nature of haters and we're actually
talking on a podcast right now about the
nature of him well some would say hey if
you don't have haters you're doing
something wrong meaning you're not doing
something big enough for the jealous
people in the world to be jealous or
this is like a whole this is a whole
area that we just don't want to deal
with right I mean seriously right this
is like it's too bit this is like the
area where does not yeah that that's why
I think that's what's good what the
statement here don't being hated don't
give way to hating yeah different move
on let's not worry about it
yeah and next line that's more analyzed
alright next and yet don't look too good
nor talk too wise don't look too good
nor talk too wise so this is this is
important because this is a little bit
of dichotomy to of they don't give way
to hating don't deal in lies but at the
same time saying don't look too
good or talk to buy so you gotta keep it
real basically and you don't want to be
a know-it-all you don't want to talk
down to people you don't want to be the
the the person that comes across like oh
I would virtuous I'm more virtuous than
you that's what that line is right don't
try and look too good
like you'd never do anything wrong it's
like oh that guy got in trouble that guy
got caught in a web of lies instead of
you know jump it's like oh hey you know
what he made a mistake hope good luck to
him I hope he can figure it out when he
finds the right path out of his
situation instead of you talking like oh
I'm that would never happen to me
because I'm virtuous yeah or talk to
wise which isn't you know I know
everything right yeah I think that's
yeah people that are trying to come
across you know what remember when we
were on with captain Charlie plum and
Jim Conkle and they were trying to drag
me into being like them they're kind you
know like I you know what we're were
your warriors like you Jocko and I was
like no guys are totally like not just
not just like more heroic than me but on
top of that better people like I'm like
a rat running around compared to those
guys and and so yeah I'm not ever trying
to be you know a guy that's saying oh
yeah well I'm I'm I'm virtuous and
you're not no hey man we're all
struggling yeah
could this mean to you know it says
don't look too good north to what like
you know how okay this is the concept
where you know when people make speeches
or they'll fit they'll have some sales
pitch or something and don't want every
word to be perfect but then when a 1-up
sales pitch is like super perfect it
doesn't connect as well as if it's just
a person talking normal to you know
saying um and all this just that idea
you know like so if someone's focusing
so hard and being like perfect in every
way and like knowing every single
possible thing and they're not showing
any flaws like focusing on it maybe
that's a mistake because they
created disconnect I actually I don't
think that's what this is talking about
but I think it is correct so I don't
give you the example from my perspective
one of the reasons that podcasts right
now do really well is because they're
normal people talking like normal people
yes and I think that if if pod and and
there are podcasts out there that are
way polished and everything and I don't
like to listen to those podcasts that
are all polished right I don't run
there's very few actually I can't think
of any uh any of the podcasts that I
actually like are that are polished
to that end degree right because that's
when you're talking about you know
highly produced with the background
music and all that stuff like those
podcasts I I don't I don't like those as
much yeah I don't like this but and even
when you talk about the produced part
like hardcore history he's still talking
he's he's still talking I mean obviously
Journal gonna obviously Tim Ferriss I
even martyr made right martyr made he's
he's he's talking right he's not just
making things happen so I think there's
something to that there's something to
the fact that we're not talking about
doing everything perfect for sure yeah
for sure
yeah agree I think if if this podcast
well this podcast would be sound like
it'd be like welcome to welcome to the
jaakko podcast this is episode 140 we're
here to talk to you today about a
Richard Kipling he was born in Popeye
just one of those who wants to listen to
that yeah yeah yeah yeah if it sounds
like well cuz because I think anyway and
it has a lot to do with like what you're
used to you know where like if you're
used to like a polished presentation and
then all of a sudden it's not polished
it's like oh he kind of fumbled through
that well there's a difference between
not polished and I have also heard
podcasts that are not prepared or not
professional right yeah yeah that's
another end the other end the spectrum
and you can there's a dichotomy yes you
can go too far sometimes I think people
just they think well Joe Rogan he just
pressed his record and talks yeah when
they think that that's just what that is
oh I can do that yeah I'll just press
record and I'll talk with this other guy
and then you then you listen to them and
you think there's a reason why Joe Rogan
is so popular yes
the reason is Jo Rowan so popular is
because even when he's just conversing
he's got a skill set that he was
probably born with and then he honed it
as a comedian and then he honed it as an
actor then he honed it as a as a
announcer for the UFC and then he
started this podcast and so he was
already good at and then he's done 1,500
pound casts that are two three and four
hours long so guess what you get good at
figuring out you listen to yourself go
oh that didn't sound good and so so
there's a big difference yes there's
podcast that people just think they're
gonna hit record and just talk and it's
gonna be super cool mm-hmm dichotomy not
cool yeah hard to listen to some of
those are hard to listen to mmm got a
gut through them mmm so check all right
next line if you can dream and not make
dreams your master that one's pretty
pretty that's a pretty awesome line
right that's a pretty awesome line and
there's I've it's a dichotomy yes dream
but don't make him your master
don't make dreams your living reality
right live in reality not in the world
of dreams if your dreams are your master
what are you actually doing daydreaming
on today dream it all day you got to
make something happen yeah that's what's
got to go down next very similar if you
can think and not make thoughts your aim
so yes of course thing but don't make
your goal to sit around a thing and I
think in my mind when I hear this maybe
I'm my own personal biases coming into
it this seems like a little shot at
philosophers mm-hmm and academics right
that sit around all day and what they're
doing is they're thinking that's what
they do
mm-hmm little shot at those guys because
don't make thoughts your aim you want to
actually go and do things you want to
make things happen you want to live that
hmm there's a difference there yeah and
that's actually that's like because you
know how like I feel like you're kind of
the example of that like when I start
saying to eat whether be on this thing
or or even in real life where I'll start
explaining something because I'll be
super interested in like how this thing
works and
did you see what happened to explain and
then your attitude has always been like
yeah okay like okay give me an example
what do you mean by real life outside of
recording like analyze like if someone's
like if I were to talk about haters like
I could analyze that or you know yes
separate podcast with Charles podcast I
was like you know what people have
dynamics of haters the episode was how
people have the whole series bro but
you'll be like alright you know okay we
understand is you you do it for more
like hey we're gonna understand so we
can take action or you know whatever
I'll just explain the understanding
because it's fun to explain the
understand and assume saying I'm looking
for application of that knowledge
so usually leadership situations yes yes
exactly right and then you'll it seems
like like you'll dig into like
understanding it like as deep as you
have to take action and that's it no
deeper you know I'm not gonna sit around
and meditate that's what it seems like
your channel yeah yeah and also I think
that this the understanding of the broad
concept is more important than the in
the minutia yeah you got to understand
the details yes but you won't understand
the broad concept and then you can move
forward and you know what you're dealing
with yeah straight forward then an
academic type as weak as the example as
your example custom talks about like
they'll they're kind of goal is the is
the thought is to analyze anew see how
this works and that's the whole goal
their goal is never really to take
action someone's gonna take action but
their their goal is the thought of it
that's what it seems fine I think that's
one thing that Dan Carlin from hardcore
history does is he so he like a lot of
times I'm comparing what I'm reading
about in historical situations to what I
either been through myself or or other
books that I've read other situations
that know about Dan Carlin does one book
to another book are one time to another
pub time but then the other thing that
he does is he takes it to us like he'll
he'll say imagine if you were imagine if
America right now elected a person that
he so he brings it into like a real time
yeah
that's his to me that's what makes
that's part of what makes his long
things that make his podcast excellent
but that's one of the things that makes
it very engaging as he brings it to
imagine if this happened today yeah
imagine if the Germans attack you know
he just brings it to today so it makes
you think about it yeah and he compares
it to other time periods so there's some
similarities there but his thoughts
aren't his aims yeah
I don't think yeah and I wouldn't even
well I think you I think what I just
said that I think he takes the thoughts
and applies them to current times right
that's what makes it interesting yeah I
wanna again one of the things that makes
it interesting yeah and I wouldn't even
say be the thoughts of being your aims
is necessarily a bad thing across the
board I think in with you know obviously
his approach it is but you know another
person who's just kind of gets a huge
payoff in figuring out how things work
and that's sort of it you know like in
here in it's kinda like hey if I'm gonna
you know I'm gonna figure out how this I
don't know this engine motor works it's
up to the engine builder to build more
engines or to build the better and just
whatever works yeah they're just really
interested in how things work you know
yeah is it possible to be super you know
like people that want to understand
jujitsu but they don't want to do it
that one moves but they don't want to
wrong well there is that for sure oh
yeah there's that and I mean depending
on who you are obviously that philosophy
won't kind of jive with you with your
whole thing but yeah I could see how
that could be if someone's like yeah
like I don't know someone who's not into
MIT necessarily the physical part of it
as much as the mental part and maybe
like the watch hitter yeah and I suppose
some guys that can't train hard anymore
because whatever they got injured or
whatever and they still are into it oh
yeah or these coaches that like maybe
were so good or something but they like
they know then they're like the best
coach and you know that can person yeah
John Danaher he doesn't have any World
Championships under his belt I don't
think yeah no name would group drag
Jackson I don't think Greg Jackson get
Greg Jackson's never even fought MMA I
don't think not one time yeah one of the
best coaches oh yes coaches ever so yeah
so you get that kind of person but would
it be saying that he made his thoughts
his aim no
put those he applied them yeah yeah well
then again swinging a mess academics
though see I'm saying like the an
academic type person maybe their
professor or something they teach about
business or sales they don't own a
business they're a professor but they
teach about business all the stuff so
that's kind of its kind of their their
thoughts or their aims is kind of like
that's their action that's that's
they're putting their thoughts into
action so I guess is less of a shot then
maybe I read it as originally okay so
the loss resonated all right well now I
think you're right I think you're right
all right next if you can meet with
triumph and disaster and treat those two
Impostors just the same what a line that
is triumph and disasters and he calls
them both imposters
he calls both triumph and disaster calls
them both Impostors why is that because
they are because they are because
neither triumph or disaster is an
end-all or be-all neither of em they
feel like it at the time when you raise
your hands and you get the victory
mm-hmm you feel like that is a be all
end all but as Patton said all glory is
fleeting right that that triumph is
gonna fade triumph isn't in eternal
victory
it's an impostor of one and this is
what's important does that and this is
the one that's harder for people to
overcome is that disasters the same way
some things happen to us and it seems
like it's the end of the world hmm
but it's not disaster is also an
impostor that's not you know what this
happens to it this happens to teenage
kids in their little relationships right
right teenaged kids and their
relationships they break up and they
think it's the end of the world and if
they only knew that in three years they
wouldn't even remember that person's
name yeah he won't even remember that
person you could never tell him that no
you can't ever be like that you couldn't
convince them in a million years not
said that that that in three years they
will not remember that person's
not even close not even close you care
doc this is the mind a crazy thing and
you both know this factually a
girlfriend that you had when you were 14
years old at that time there was no way
that you were ever gonna think about
another girl that was the one you know
right now you don't know what her name
was
you better leave remember what she looks
like come on yes but that's what he's
saying yeah that when that girl breaks
up with you or guy if you're if you're a
girl the good guy that broke your heart
you're not even remember this leg and
you know what he's doing now
not much hmm not much don't worry about
that dude I don't know maybe yeah I
guess that's a good point
maybe maybe you do well the line most
likely yeah these disasters that you
have and then you know you tease either
that's an easy one but you know your
business has a big issue hmm oh it's
gonna man this within six months of
opening victory MMA the roof collapsed
you remember that the the drunk driver
hit a fire hydrant out in front of the
building the fire hydrant actually broke
off and the pipes just started squirting
I mean how big around is up is a fire
hydrant it's up is that 12 inches water
or something Oh a 12 inch water line
started spraying up and on to the top
roof the building which is no big deal
cuz you know roofs are they're meant to
take water well what happened was the
little drains because the flat roofs the
little drains up there since it doesn't
rain a lot in California they had debris
and they filled up the drains filled up
and then the next thing you know the
roof just filled with water inside the
parapet wall and the roof collapsed I
was in six months of work opening up we
I think we had just started making money
boom we got no we got half the building
is gone the air conditioners from the
second floor from the roof are on the
bottom floor of the building in the
mixed martial arts area it was bad but
you know when it seems like a big
disaster guess what
get it get it taken care of it's like we
move on guess what the gym still ten
years old still going strong yeah so
these bad things are gonna happen
the
disasters are gonna happen but they're
not permanent yeah they're not the
be-all end-all they're not the end of
the world and the victories the triumphs
are the same thing they're not gonna
last
don't rest on your laurels stay centered
so stay balanced so did you guys end up
clearing out the drains or what the
drains yeah we cleared them out could a
day late and a dollar short
yeah next if you can bear to hear the
truth you've spoken twisted by knaves to
make a trap for fools
so you're go out and you tell the truth
right and then the truth that you tell
gets twisted around by some knave which
is an unscrupulous person it's it's a
dishonest first right let's bring that
work back sir it's pretty nice 15 names
they're gonna twist your words and
you're gonna have to bear it and the
reason that this is what I think is
interesting the reason that you have to
bear it is because if you get drawn into
it it's trap it's a trap that you're
gonna get drawn into if you start
dealing with what if you start going in
and trying to trying to untwist this
this lies that have been told about you
it's a trap that's what you say you it's
almost like a battle you can't win and
by entering the battlefield you're gonna
get wounded yeah so what is this like
some you know like someone will say
something I don't know and it'll like
involve race won't be racist but I like
involve race because that's how the
explanation pans out you know on TV or
something and then someone else will
come in but oh my gosh this person's
racist cuz look what he said and maybe
they'll play like you know the end part
of the tape only or the beginning only
or something like that and then they'll
someone else would be like hey you know
this interview you know they'll ask this
question hey did you say this and
they'll be like well yeah I said that uh
it's and then someone else will come and
be like look he even admitted he said
this thing but then you know and then so
that it just keeps getting twisted and
interested it's like that and then the
more you explain it the more you can't
wait wait you're saying you didn't say
there's no idea okay
you did or you didn't kind of you know
it's like that I think that's definitely
part of it and probably that's it I mean
that that's it when you go and try and
unwind these things you're probably
gonna dig yourself a bigger hole I think
that's that the overall yeah yeah good
now that are there times where people
say something that's so horrible or
didn't see that you have to finish up
sure that can happen I think when you do
that you keep it simple you keep it
direct and then you walk away right yeah
see look I would never have done that or
I would never have said that or whatever
and that's all I'm gonna say walk away
break the wrist walk away all right next
or watch the things you gave your life
to broken and stoop and build them up
with worn-out tools so you gave your
life to whatever your life's works you
gave it all and and that thing is broken
it's destroyed and what you do is you
stoop I like that word because what does
that mean it means you're bending down
that means you're bowing down right
you're having to get down if the stoop
down you go to the ground and begin to
rebuild what has been destroyed and you
do it with worn-out tools now we're not
just talking about worn-out physical
tools like a hammer and a saw we're
talking about you mmm we're talking
about a worn-out broken down you you are
broken down and you're worn out but you
go anyway and you start from the
beginning and you rebuild again that's
legit yeah remember the game contra no
okay there's game I don't even knowing
that is until called Kyra have Nintendo
won't dang bro that's too bad but
there's this game named contra any new
new play Nintendo knows this game was
freaking awesome
this code is basically these two guys if
you go one player you go one player 2
player 2 players play on the same screen
and you just go it's like this basic
side angle game these commando rambles
side angle side angle yeah it's not like
you know you know instead of a first
person it's just a sighting and it's
these Rambo guys you go to Claire they
both play on the same screen
boom against each other know with each
other okay
so boom they killed bad guys right okay
so through the game you can get
different weapons okay so and each
weapon is like more and more effective
right so you can get the basic shooter
is what you start with and you have a
machine gun you just hold the button
down it goes perfect and it just machine
gun then there's like a laser that just
can go and it can just kill like five
people in a row like that can and
there's then there's the spreader it's a
spread gun so to cite a side angle game
multi-level kind of thing the spreader
it just kills everybody boom boom so one
you go can you kill your own person to
accident no no boom your bullets no no
it's not really this game is awful there
are someone realistic if I had behaved
there'd be some situations you get into
they teach you about combat you want to
teach you about the spreader yeah well
to teach you about blue-on-blue teach
about fratricide all right yeah human
lost I dig it in the probably be a heavy
game but contra it's not like that so
when you get to the point is the point
is following here the point is when you
get the spreader you can make it super
far because you're just killing now die
if you have this infinite weapon roads
well someone can still kill you if you
mess you know someone shoots you just
like any other way you can die but since
you have the spreader that's just
killing everyone so easily you make it
to high levels you see I'm saying but
here's the thing about concho when you
get killed you get like you get three
men right I know I'm realistic but still
that's most video games anyway you three
men if you've been killed you lose the
spreader you start you start again where
you were but you still you get that
peashooter again the one you first
started with so it's that same thing so
you go through all the levels you work
so hard to get the spreader
you know is this you have three men you
have to realize this is a thing yeah
here's the okay and which is another
thing about country which is so awesome
you have three lives but if you know the
code in the beginning of the game you
can get thirty lives and here's the code
up up down down left right left right B
a and press Start that's the code it
gives you 30 life everyone knows that
I'll I will 100% guarantee that every
single person every single person that
is played concert knows that code not
even like 99 percent 100 or so yeah
because you get 10 times the amount of
effectiveness yeah so but it's a secret
code it's not like it comes with a game
like you got 100 percent like 88 or 80
not whenever that game announcer webs 3
into yeah what everything there be
interesting to track how that
information spread Yeah right yeah back
then how did it spread up down down left
left a B how did that spread on it was
no more than a gun there was no internet
yeah that's true no viable Internet
yeah it's true the kids for damn sure
weren't on it I don't know so your point
is that this taught you once yet you
will use those worn-out tools that
you'll still try and go back and rebuild
Contras like the bad Kipling is dead did
not hear this apologize if he understood
the concept he'd be like you were
exactly right guys here's the thing
listen to the practicality of this
because with the spread okay if you just
had the pea shooter all right we'll call
it the pea shooter that's the gun that
you start with if you start with that
it's really hard to make it to a high
level because it's like the levels get
harder and hard and you just got that
pea shooter but those guys are gonna
kill you but if you get the spreader
it's the exact opposite you can smash
through levels right and some of the
levels at the end you gotta have a
powerful weapon to beat the boss
you seem sane so if you have the
spreader you can get pretty far
what's I've heard people who use the
term boss is there a term called king
boss or main boss or end boss and by
main bus and bus enforcer and then this
is a universal term maybe with video
games with video games right and that's
my question
bosses but what do we know where the
term originated from lost who is the
original end boss
I don't video that someone made that's
really really funny
it's called it's something about it's
about me and it's it's a German guy and
it's like how did Jocko Whelan get so
massive
yeah have you seen that video who what
what was it he just makes a video where
he breaks down how I got so massive yeah
yeah yeah yeah hilarious yes but one
thing he goes this is the ad jock was
the end boss to kill oh yeah I didn't
really know what an boss was so I
googled it and I figured out that it's
from the video game world when boss do
you remember the date oh no that is it
like an old-school game like Atari no no
it's the video game world no no the
video game video game in the video games
you you're a little taken aback was this
man world that giving my spreader I'll
go get some levels game called kung foo
and original Nintendo's called kung fu 5
levels but then they repeat and they get
hurt in hard but there's five levels and
they I think in the game it called them
the boss like the first level bar might
be in the second of a block but I'm sure
I'm sure there's because there's other
older games with bosses on them yeah
nonetheless well Kipling would say
because all the point is when you get
the spreader gameplay you'll encounter
when you get the spreader if you get
you'll make it to a high level you will
but here's the thing that high level is
super hard so you need that spreader and
if you get hit and you die when you know
when you come back to life or whatever
you got the pea shooter you find
yourself for like this with worn-out
tools that's what you find yourself and
it's hard and if you put your mind to it
you can get that spread again but it's
really hard super hard
anyone who play controls will attest to
that I think that right there is we'll
leave it at that
that's my recommendation alright next if
you can make one heap of all your
winnings and risk it on one turn of
pitch-and-toss and lose and start again
at your beginnings and never breathe a
word about your loss never breathe a
word about your loss isn't it when you
meet someone and you you talk to him
when you deal with them for a while and
they don't tell you anything about their
background and then you find out like
later that they've been through some big
struggle it's so much more impactful and
impressive
yeah then when they're like hey I did
this and I went through that night
you know just I got a good idea just be
quiet don't breathe a word about your
loss yeah just move just just perform
yeah and this is also about being
willing to take risk willing to take
risk this seems like an inappropriate
risk to risk everything that you have on
a single turn of pitch-and-toss doesn't
seem like a smart risk no Richard
Kipling I don't know about that one yeah
take it easy I'm gonna say let's let's
let's dial the dichotomy back of the
extreme betting situation all right that
being said you absolutely have to take
risks in life right like something like
a teeny tiny thing got to be a no risk
no reward Norris but let's not risk
everything in one turn of pitch-and-toss
let's not do that next if you can force
your heart and nerve and sinew to serve
your turn long after they are gone
that's just awesome right we're talking
about forcing your heart in your nerve
and your sinuan sinews up basically
means your tendons and your ligaments
and the things that hold your muscles
and your bones together and you know use
Shakespeare used sinew quite a bit
because it's just like the core element
but this is like saying you will get you
will force your body and your mind to do
what you need them to do even when
they're done they're done we're gonna
force them to do more when they have
nothing left to give you're gonna force
them to give anyways and then it rolls
right into the next line the next line
and so hold on when there is nothing in
you except the will which says to them
hold on you got nothing left but will mm
force of will to make make them make
make your heart and make your nerve make
them hold the line if you can talk with
crowds and keep your virtue or walk with
Kings nor lose the common touch so this
is again this is staying balanced this
is like
to me no matter if you're involved with
the masses right even if you're involved
with the masses you don't lose your
virtue or if you're rubbing elbows with
the rich and powerful with the Kings you
don't lose that common touch you stay
grounded you don't lose the ability to
communicate with people up and down the
chain of command from a leadership
perspective no matter what station
someone is in life you remember remember
episode 5 of this podcast I read a
counseling letter to a good guy and I
was like hey treat everyone respect oh 1
or e 1 2 Oh 10 like it doesn't matter
what rank someone does he treat them
with respect no matter what
don't lose that next if neither friends
nor loving if either if neither foes nor
loving friends can hurt you this is
what's interesting
it isn't always your enemies that hurt
you right in fact it's quite the
opposite usually the people that hurt
you the most are the people that are
closest to you those the ones that
really put the dagger in and twist it so
you're gonna be above that you got a you
got kind of insulate yourself from that
you can't leave that last little bit of
exposure in my opinion you got it you've
got to keep a little bit right you got
to keep a little bit you got to keep it
you got to put yourself in a situation
where you're not gonna get crushed by
your foes or by the people that you're
close to
yeah it's hard and keeping it is hard it
is hard guys get jammed up right really
deco Charles terminology that jams
people up all time if the enemy doesn't
Jam people up as bad as the the friends
right yeah because the enemy expect that
you expect them trying to jam you oh
yeah but this goes back to the original
what we talked about earlier that the
person and we've talked about this on
the podcast the person that hurts you
really bad that was your friend they
weren't your friend
you know they didn't exist the police
you thought you knew them you thought
you understood them you thought they
were trust what they weren't so just we
have to just look at it's a look of that
person that I was in love with or that
person that I thought was gonna be with
me although guess what that that person
doesn't exist so we got to move on
so you got to keep I think a little bit
and this might sound cold-blooded right
it sounds a little bit cold-blooded to
be like laughs glad you got to keep some
stuff you got to kind of keep
perspective you got to keep people in
check yeah and if you let them get in to
the point where they can rip you apart
you're gonna be careful you've got to be
careful you decide you're gonna do that
with real careful yeah yeah or you or
this is I think what I do is more like
this if that happens I recognize it okay
this this is what happened boom that
person wasn't who I thought they were
we're moving on yeah we're moving on
yeah man this quest you know what I mean
we're moving on yeah so I guess they
maybe I have the ability I shouldn't say
that I have the ability I think I
learned along the way
Hey once someone exposes themselves
reveals themselves as a as a knave
ranae's once they reveal themselves as a
knave I'm over it
yeah I'm moving on because I they've
exposed they've revealed great I'm
actually happy that now I don't have to
invest any more time effort into this
person that's a knave a wretched Navy
needs yeah and then you you have a this
kind of how should I say over developed
control of your emotions we'll call it
where like the average person is like
it's kind of like if you built a house
right you built a house on koi and it's
a nice house lived there for 10 years 15
years even a lot of memories in that
house maybe even had some kids whatever
first dog all that stuff and that a
hurricane comes blows it down right
there's really nothing you could have
done you know like if you had a
girlfriend then she doesn't have the
signs of being a knave but then maybe
she changed maybe she was that all along
I don't know she
as it turns out name the house gets
blown down okay
girlfriends gone you can either easily
say hey that was that wasn't the girl
that I loved all this stuff okay we're
moving on obviously you gotta move on
right she's a knave yeah if you're
squared away in your hands yeah you got
a move on you know that righty but you
can't just be like yo just move on what
about ho this is turmeric I'm talking
about both so yeah I'll go back the
hurricane series relies the man the
knave the memories realize yeah well
yeah but emotionally it doesn't end that
guess what you're free
okay so let me you got away let's see
how steep okay let's take the knave
that's good that's good but you're
talking about like practically how much
you learned you learned that you gave
you be careful let's see what I'm saying
though like your sense of like emotional
control allows you to go boom right do
that one right and which one is fresh
like you can't just oh yeah look how
much I learned yay let's get moving on
that bad that's not the normal person no
approach person either has still has
open wounds from because yesterday that
house was intact yeah but and all the
way to rebuild that kitchen it that
feels good floor just been straight to
the positive thing which is the good
thing to do which is the residue but
better capability was the average person
can't do that so no it's good might be a
little bit tricky but what are the
options what are the options there's no
option the option is oh I'm gonna be
distressed and mourn the loss of my
house even more than the loss your house
do it for a you know at four days yeah
there should be a limitation yeah that's
a good idea huh be like hey one week
right now I'm gonna just let my emotions
just be my emotions yeah right not to
like a week too long yeah for a house
for sure no that's that's that's one of
the things that work for the girlfriend
yeah for a girlfriend yeah that's a bit
but we'll go months right no people go
years people talk about it for years
that's not good that's what I'm saying
that's that's my point see instead of
making me sound like I'm all cold
blooded over here well what you should
say is like hey I wish that some of the
people that I know that wrecked their
lives over a girlfriend boyfriend
husband wife that broke up with him and
they let it ruin their
I wish you'd say hey I wish that they
would have had enough to emotional
control to say you know what all right
it's day three they're not coming back I
have two choices
dig a hole climb in it never come out or
step up make things happen you move
forward the choice is obvious and once
you step up and you start moving forward
in three years you'll remember that
person's name anymore they're no factor
yeah you're no factor yeah yeah so
what's the I mean obviously it's gonna
be depend on what kind of person it is
so I've talked about this like we don't
have a good a good system yeah when
someone dies in America we don't really
know what to do because in other
countries in other in other cultures
they have a specific ritual that they go
through and and in America our rituals
are kind of all jammed together and then
we don't really know what the right
ritual is right we don't even know how
to dispose the body do we do we burn it
do we bury it do we buried it seat like
there's all these options yeah do you
donate your organs do you not is just
like oh I'll do you know knit to your
body to science well what are we what
are you supposed to do what's the right
thing to do we don't even know that we
even know what to do with someone's body
so how are we supposed to know what
we're supposed to do emotionally when
someone dies what are we supposed to do
yeah we don't have a physical ritual to
do so what now what do we do yeah and so
that's the same thing like there should
be rules hey probably call yes a
protocol broke up with significant other
here's the protocol yeah one day
mourning one pizza extra cheese
pepperoni sausage right mint chocolate
chip milkshake sure cool next day vodka
no no no no I I don't recommend it I
don't neither direction yeah
the next day I was like what I was gonna
say is like I was gonna say eight Mile
Run eight Mile Run that's just what you
got here yeah hey oh I bring you out
what are you doing some all yeah we rock
on my girlfriend two days ago I got a
started protocol yeah yeah oh you oh and
there could be different levels oh I was
going out with her
for every let's say for every three
months that you were with her
that's one Milan man okay yeah good and
so then you do that and we get done with
that guess what you got to do you got to
do a you got to do what a contrast bath
ice hot ice hot yeah you got to do that
four times right yeah no what you do is
a good protocol for a contrast baths
five minutes ice five minutes heat 4
minutes ice performance you go back and
forth when you get done with that boom
you come out you're cleansed and then
guess what
24-hour fast right 24 hours well what
that actually kind of sounds weird like
for a breakup but know so many cultures
do that oh yeah you got a fast you get a
fast for this so and so then we could go
on and on but you make a protocol it's a
three-day protocol generally and then
BOOM now we come out of that protocol
and then there's one last the last thing
on the protocol is like go to work or
you know begin normal routine back to
normal routine you go to bed back to oh
I know the final protocol is wake up
whatever time it is you get up in the
morning third fourth day now the
protocol has been completed fourth day
boom wake up get get busy get on with it
get after it that's what I'm talking
about so we don't have that so if you if
you put in your mind I think for me I
recognize when something is dragging me
this is dragging me in the wrong
direction as soon as I see something
dragging me in the wrong direction I
know like the internal protocol it's
like okay I'm emotionally attached to
this situation it's not beneficial to me
mmm it's not beneficial to me it's not
gonna help me it's not gonna help me
understand the nature of the world it's
not gonna help me move forward with my
life it's not gonna help me in any way
guess I'm gonna do I'm gonna detach
we're gonna take a little step away from
that thing yeah because I'm not saying
emotions are bad emotions are great
that's what makes us human beings right
I get emotional on this podcast right
sure that's not bad no that's actually
good makes me understand myself and
other things in the world better but
that's a positive effect of emotions but
if I start having negative emotions and
they start dragging me down protocol
yeah execute the protocol boom that's
what we need to do
yeah like what if like part of the
protocol was like to shave your head or
something right Andrea yeah like that
could be right and then let's say like
you you break up with your girlfriend or
something and then like you know a few
days later you see her at the post
office or some she has a shaved head
you're like oh man she's getting over me
quick yeah I'm saying yeah but that
would help though that way totally would
because it's like it's like but it's
like the process and it gives you
something else to focus on
seems saying so it's like okay I'm not
talking about the protocol and you call
it having a protocol especially it
expands like you know three four days
boom boom boom it's like you know
doesn't a a have something like that to
wear yeah no calls all kinds of things
there's a reason protocols exist yeah
because it gives you something to fall
you don't have to think about it and it
moves you in the right direction yeah
yeah so think about that for your life
pay attention to it cuz the scary part
about this and we've talked about this
too it's like the storm your heads in a
storm and you can't get out and the only
person everyone else can see that your
head has a has a has a two-foot cloud
around it yeah and everybody can see if
you just move in a direction you'll get
away from that cloud but everywhere you
look you just see storm is club and
thunder and lightning so you don't think
there's any way out but there is just
got to execute the protocol the puter
protocol as you go due north 1,800
meters you're gonna be out right that's
what's gonna happen shave your head run
the eight miles eat a pizza eat a mint
chocolate chip milkshake that's day one
that's a little comfort yeah little
luxury feel Vaughn luxury style next we
went way off on that one Bret that was
good that was actually really good that
kind of gets you thinking because if you
you could even do this right now if
you're in even if you're in early even
if you're not even in a relationship yet
cuz those are the waters right just get
prepare a protocol yeah like hey if this
cuz it's kind of like a natural disaster
you do that you know what there's also
there's also something you could do that
would be helpful and I hate to use this
word because you get to use it in a
different sense these days but you can
have trigger points right things that
happen where if you see if you identify
things happening you go okay if I get
involved in this situation and
this happens that's a trigger that means
I need to walk right for instance let's
say you have someone that has let's say
let's say you meet someone that was an
addict of some kind mm-hmm an alcoholic
and you're like okay if this person
starts drinking that's my trigger I'm
gonna walk mmm because you don't want to
go down that spiral with them right or
you whatever the case may be you have
someone that used to date some other guy
like hey if I see that there's whatever
a facebook connection again I'll walk it
whatever like you gotta you figure out
these things and that way you
predetermine them when you're in a non
emotional state yeah and you get to the
emotional state hopefully you can
overcome your emotions because there's
like I don't care I love I love her I'm
just gonna keep going there's only this
one time right yeah she friended me
right and then they they stick around
but if you have your protocol in place
you have the triggers to execute a bond
it's gonna make it easier for you it
should make it easy for you mmm all
right next one this is a good one if all
men count with you but none too much and
think about this one I've got we
actually got wrapped around this one a
little bit in the podcast one time
because this is a dichotomy of the fact
that I personally there's part of me
that doesn't care what anyone thinks
and then there's part of me that
completely cares about what people are
specifically people that I have a lot of
respect for I care what they think a lot
and people that I don't respect I don't
care what they think so there's a
dichotomy there and that's similar to
what is being said here if all men count
with you so you take their opinions you
understand but at the same time none to
much you know to sway you from the path
yeah
and here next line I think this one
Grey's line lines ever if you can kill
if you can fill the unforgiving minute
with sixty seconds worth of distance run
so the unforgiving minute that's a great
that's the way you should think of every
minute every minute that exists
for you is unforgiving because it does
not stop it does not forgive and you
can't have it back
that's the unforgiving minute time has
no mercy on anyone and what he's saying
here is if you can fill every one of
those unforgiving minutes of your life
every single one of them with a full 60
seconds of you running and moving
forward and getting after it if you can
push that hard if you can push that hard
then he closes out yours is the earth
and everything that's in it and which is
more you'll be a man my son so there it
is if you can do all those things and
that's the name of the poem if if you
can do those things those things that
are simple but not easy simple but
definitely not easy then the world will
be yours and you will be a man meant in
the most positive possible way so now
we'd go back this is what we do now that
we understand it fully we go through it
fully here it goes
if if you can keep your head when all
about you are losing theirs and blaming
it on you if you can trust yourself when
all men doubt you but make allowance for
their doubting too if you can wait and
not be tired by waiting or being lied
about don't deal lies or being hated
don't give way to hating and yet don't
look too good nor talk too wise if you
can dream and not make dreams your
master if you can think
and not make thoughts your aim if you
can meet with triumph and disaster and
treat those two Impostors just the same
if you can bear to hear the truth you've
spoken twisted by knaves to make a trap
for fools or watch the things you gave
your life to broken and stoop and build
them up with worn-out tools if you can
make one heap of all your winnings and
risk it on one turn of pitch-and-toss
and lose and start again at your
beginnings and never breathe a word
about your loss if you can force your
heart and nerve and sinew to serve your
turn long after they are gone and so
hold on when there is nothing in you
except the will which says to them hold
on if you can talk with crowds and keep
your virtue or walk with Kings nor lose
the common touch if neither foes nor
loving friends can hurt you if all men
count with you but none too much if you
can fill the unforgiving minute with
sixty Seconds worth of distance run
yours is the earth and everything that's
in it and which is more you'll be a man
my son and there you have it some pretty
straightforward instructions from
Kipling on how to live and I looked at
it and his son died in World War one he
wrote this poem just before the turn of
the century so he wrote this poem before
his son was killed before his son went
to war perhaps just after his son was
born in that time
frame I'm sure his son grew up with
these thoughts and I think it's thoughts
that we can all use so Kipling thank you
and now we are going to go through some
QA digging to a little bit QA echo
Charles mm-hmm
first question first question
yeah chuckle many times he said that
liking a fight or liking to fight should
be a part of every man's personality
could you expand on that I've always
been interested in martial arts but I
have always been reluctant to fight and
I would do anything not to does that
make me less of a man so obviously this
is a pretty fitting question for the
situation yeah so this is obviously a
good question and a fitting question
talking about being a man I don't know
if I said liking to fight you should be
a part of everybody's every man's
personality or if I said that it is part
of every man's personality any I think I
said is part of their personality and if
I said that what I think I should have
said as most right most men have in
their personality some level of interest
of fighting right we wrestle we box we
scrap as kids look at the UFC right why
is the UFC so popular right now because
it's fighting and we have that that's a
I read the other that's a seven billion
dollar organization that's a there's a
lot of people watching those fights
mm-hmm a lot of people want to watch
those fights we have boxing we have
wrestling we have jiu-jitsu we have
Judah we have Muay Thai we have all
kinds of martial arts schools so while I
don't think the desire to fight is
inherent in all men right I'm sure
there's men out there that have not into
it at all but I think it's definitely a
pretty strong part of many men now for
this individual particular
do do I think that being reluctant to
fight makes you less of a man no
actually I think it's fine
you should be reluctant to fight I think
everyone should be reluctant there's a
lot of bad things that can happen in a
fight a lot of bad things you know first
of all you get hurt right that's bad you
can get seriously hurt you can get
killed you can get killed you can get
punched one time fall down hit a curb
and die you can think you're gonna get
in a fair fight with someone they can
stab you in the neck and kill you right
these things can happen even if it's not
that bad you can hurt someone else now
you're getting lawsuit now you're
getting put in prison right so there's
all kinds of bad things so being
reluctant to fight is actually a good
thing and it's something that men should
have and actually the more you know
about fighting the more reluctant you
will be I was way the less I knew in my
life about fighting the more or sorry
the more I actually knew about fighting
the more reluctant I became to fight
because I realized all the risks that
are involved part that was maturity sure
but the reality is you look at someone
you go I don't know who that person is a
they they might be training I'm over
here thinking arbitrated Jitsu for eight
months I'm ready to kick this guy's ass
meanwhile you don't know that guy is a
purple belt guess what's gonna happen to
you you're getting crushed yeah or that
guy wrestled in high school he's about
to double like you and slam you on a
curb
you're gonna die so you should be
reluctant to fight that's a good thing
now that being said I do recommend that
you are prepared to fight I definitely
recommend that and there's gonna be a
big dichotomy here I'm gonna get to but
you should know some basics right you
should understand threats you should not
have contend with other people you
should you know you should know some
boxing you should know some wrestling
you should know some more times you know
some jiu-jitsu for sure
because here's the dichotomy this is
that this is a big dichotomy and think
about it it's a hundred percent true if
this this individual says he would do
anything not to fight would do anything
not to fight let me tell you the best
thing you can do as a human so that you
don't have to fight is actually
how to fight that is the best way to not
have to fight is if you know how to
fight if you know how to fight people
are gonna want to fight you you don't
have to say anything they can tell you
can tell when you meet somebody you can
tell if that person oh if you if you're
ready to fight people don't want to
fight you the more eager you are to
fight the less people want to fight you
if you don't know how to fight and and
bullies because that's what we're
talking about bullies see that you don't
want to fight guess who they're coming
after you now guess what now you have to
fight but if you know how to fight and
you have that confidence and you have
that understanding and you learn simple
things like avoidance and you learned
you have better situational awareness
you become a threat to the people that
want to fight you if you become a threat
to them just by just by your knowledge
alone mmm so no you're not less of a man
because you're elected to fight you
actually should be reluctant to fight
but you should learn how to fight
because the best way to avoid fighting
them more equipped and prepared to fight
you are the less you will have to fight
the less you will be put in positions
where you have to fight and the better
the outcome will be if it does happen to
occur
yeah interestingly like a lot of the
people that you meet in jujitsu are just
like this where I'm interested in
martial arts but I'm not interested in
fighting nobody sure you know for sure
and then they learn and I get oh well
there's a strong component of nerds in
jujitsu right strong component oh yeah
really strong of of you know people I'm
saying it jokingly but there's just this
studious type yes students protect
people that aren't super physical
they're more cerebral than they are
physical yeah there's a ton of people
like that and you know what they'll do
choke you out yeah they'll end up being
real good yeah they wind up being real
good because they're like oh I
understand this there's a this is a game
that I can learn and then I can crush
yeah and that's good and now I have more
confidence I don't worry about it
anymore
again it's interesting how that third or
that that additional element that
they're not really used to like how you
say nerds and you know we'll just say
like people who are more cerebral within
physical you know it's that right maybe
they can play high school sports right
that because they were working on a
computer right cool right on yeah anyway
they were playing music right yeah
whatever yeah and then now they get into
this highly physical situation cuz just
to let's face it that's physical that's
your whole body it is physical and but
you get in and you're just finding
success just by learning it it's not
like football where it's like sure I
know how to catch
I can't run fast though and I can't I'm
not being strong or whatever so I'm just
getting smashed you know I can but this
it's kind of like the more you know the
better you are kind of thing and sure
physical attributes help you for sure
buddy that is much yeah there's there's
you being stronger is great yeah you
know Dean was talking about this today
on the map the stronger guys not always
gonna win the more athletic guys not
always gonna win sometimes they do
there's various categories that will
bring you a victory one of the strongest
categories that you can have well the
distraught be strongest category is your
technique if none what to do is no one
what to do and so you you're smart
people your cerebral people that come in
and go oh I can apply I can apply this
knowledge the same way I apply my skills
in accounting James Nielson world's
toughest accountant
so that's just the reality and yeah and
that's why so now there that's why
people get addicted to because it's like
this element of physicality like a
physical fighting mark fighting sport by
the way combat sport yeah and now
they're in the end they're good at yeah
they're good at something physical for
the first time and they're still smart
as smart can be you know like they
always were so now they got that and
that additional like pay off you know
that's really get it additional power
yeah I recognize that with kids that
come to jiu-jitsu the often times and
it's not an always oftentimes the kids
that get really into jiu-jitsu our kids
that are smart and but they haven't done
a lot of other sports yet and it's
exactly what you're saying you it's very
noticeable with kids yeah the kid that
played baseball his whole life and he
comes in there he actually doesn't like
it at first and maybe doesn't even want
to do it because he's getting choked by
someone that seems all nerdy to him you
know and he knows I could throw a
baseball farther than this guy and so it
makes him mad
he doesn't want to trade yeah but
oftentimes it's the kids that come in
that really haven't done too much
athletically and you know their thing I
picked on we got we've I've had a lot of
bullies come to my jiu-jitsu kids
program the reason they're there is
because they got bullied and once they
start training six months they're not
getting bullied anymore and a year later
they're a different person yeah they're
a different kid confident assured
themselves not backing down
not being jerks not being bullies
themselves but just confident yeah so
yeah transferred you get to next
question Jocko and echo question how
important is personal intelligence in
the military particularly in more
dangerous roles as compared to physical
strength I'm a college student who will
probably go to OCS Officer Candidate
School yeah so this has been on my mind
well okay so intelligence is paramount
right of course if you aren't smart that
you're gonna do dumb things and dumb
things can definitely get you killed
this is not to say that if you do dumb
things you will get killed cuz I did
some really dumb things in combat and I
didn't get killed and it certainly isn't
to say that if you get killed you did
something dumb because to combat has no
mercy and you can be the best trained
the smartest the most tackling sound
person in the world and those people can
still get killed the combat doesn't care
about any of that that bullet that has
no one's name on it it the bomb has no
one's name on it it's gonna go off and
it's gonna take out who it takes out and
that's that but as far as weighing you
know intelligence and cognitive power
versus strength I mean you have to be is
I would rather be smart and being
smartness is very important because if
you're smart if you aren't smart I
should say you you increase your chance
of doing something that isn't smart and
then you're gonna make some kind of a
mistake that will negatively impact you
so yes being smart is very important now
there are some cases without question
where physical strength and stamina is
at least as important and sometimes more
important that's just the way it is you
might have to climb a cliff to escape
the enemy but that's just the way it is
you might have to sort Mike Thornton
Mike Thornton swam for what five hours
dragging two people now he could be the
smartest guy in the world and which he
did a damn good job of just you know
getting the life jackets and getting him
myself organizing a situation where it'd
be the easiest possible way for him to
swim even with that
you still got to swim for five hours
dragging two people while you're wounded
by the way mm-hmm so if he didn't have
that physical strength at that point
that brain wouldn't matter it wouldn't
matter so what's interesting about this
is guess what a really smart person will
get himself or herself the physical
capabilities and that's what you'll do
the smart person the really smart person
will work their ass off to get in shape
and in the stay in shape because you can
be smart to come up with the most
brilliant plan in the world but if you
don't have the physical wherewithal to
execute that plan than that that
brilliant plan doesn't matter
so yes you want to be smart and yes you
want to be physically strong you want to
exercise your brain and your body as
much as possible and get them both as
mentally strong physically get yourself
as mentally strong as physically strong
as you possibly can and that's not just
in the not just in the military that's
in life life somebody quoted on Twitter
the other day you if you - you can't you
don't know 2+2 if you're dead like you
can't add two plus there so if you're if
you're investing all your time in being
smart or you're investing all your time
and in that intellectual aspect of your
life and then you let your physical
aspect go yeah well guess what now
you're now you're unhealthy now you die
because you didn't take care you now
what good is your brain now zero zero
good jack
next wish chuckle how do you give
feedback to someone without everyone
taking it personal I try to give
criticism regarding their work or
actions while not attacking their
character but unfortunately many feel
that it's personal yeah welcome to the
world people don't like chrism criticism
and I almost put eight no one in the
world likes criticism
okay so there might be point zero zero
zero zero one percent of the world
that's really like open and ready for
feedback right but most people even when
they say even when they tell you they
want feedback they don't want it they
don't want it like it let me let me give
an example if you echo Charles yes we're
like you made a video and it took you an
hour guys don't even write you know like
you could come to me and say hey what do
you think and I was like well you know I
think you framed this up wrong how
what's your reaction to that I mean
there's no possible way that you're
stoked on that there now luckily you
know we know each other you can detach a
deck all right Lenny dude he doesn't
he's not pointing this out to me for no
reason
whatever but what I'm saying is even
when you're saying hey what do you think
of this and I criticize something that
you work so hard on there's no one in
the world that's happy about that even
when they asked for it mm-hmm so you
have to flank people that's what you
have to do now he's asking specifically
how do you do this so here's some things
what one of the things that I do when I
want to give someone criticism I don't
give him Chris's and what I do is I ask
them questions about whatever it is now
hey this is interesting
I'm not even talking about pointed
questions I'm not even talking about
like hard questions I'm talking I'm not
saying like why did you do that you know
I'm talking about hey why did you do it
that way like there's a big difference
between like hey why did you do it that
way yeah like instead of saying hey echo
that frame is doesn't look good hey
why'd you frame that up like that yeah
right so now I'm getting you to think
about it right but I'm not gonna say you
how are you gonna make that work
mmm you know I'm gonna say well hey do
you think you're gonna be able to make
that work hmm if if you did something
and it doesn't go well I'm not gonna say
you know did you actually think that was
a good idea instead I'm gonna say it's
again it's not pointing course I'm gonna
say well hey did that unfold the way you
thought it was gonna unfold and you know
you're gonna get to answer the question
now you're gonna be the you're gonna be
the person that uncovers the fault it's
gonna be you not me and that makes it so
much more palatable to everyone when
they're able to say oh yeah you know I
saw this over here and most the time the
person knows the truth most of the time
the person knows that that thing's not
framed up right they know that their
idea was that great so you don't need to
punch him in the face with it because
that's actually gonna make him get
defensive
so you flank him you ask him the
questions you talk about it you discuss
the subject and what you do is you guide
them you guide them to a mirror you
guide them to a mirror and then and then
you just have a look at that bear mm-hmm
you set him up so they have to look in
that mirror so that they can see the
problems themselves and once they see
the problems themselves they can start
to correct them now sometimes you
sometimes it's your ego that wants even
once they see the problem themselves do
people want to take credit for showing
that misleads you you've got to check
your ego you got to make sure that your
ego isn't saying I want to prove to this
person that I know how to frame this up
better then you got to put that all in
check and you gotta just let you gotta
let them have it so now are there
situations where you can give really
good frank feedback yes there is but you
have to have a good relationship with
that person a really good really good
relation if that person and then usually
one of the best ways to to make this
happen is that the feedback the negative
feedback is going both ways meaning I
want to get negative feedback about my
performance from that person so that
there's some equanimity in what's being
said amongst us right so I might be
little you know I might say echo aim and
I you know I did this I answered this
court
QA did you think that was a good answer
because I think you know I think could
have been better and then you say yeah
you know you dragged on and talked too
long and whatever you give me some
critique and then I go oh yeah hey and
by the way the lighting on that didn't
look good right and so now we have a
little mutual criticism and it's all
good it makes a little bit more
palatable to you because I made the
thing and so that sometimes works but
what's interesting is even when you do
that some people just don't even
freaking care and and they even after
they just tear you apart and then you
throw a little little like a little nick
on their shoulder on their an arm you
give them a little nick about something
that wasn't right they still get so you
have to be really you have to have a
really great relationship with that
person to be able to have just that
straight straight feedback but build
relationships ask them questions let
them find their own fault if you can and
be their guide let them guide them to
that mirror got them to their faults now
of course there are some people that
won't even find their own faults no
matter how you guide them and how hard
you try and twist them to look in the
mirror you have to let them know you
actually have to come out and say what's
going on you have to be more direct now
luckily if a person is the type of
person that fails to see their own
faults they begin to fail right because
they're making mistakes that's why their
faults right they're making mistakes and
when they see that and when you see that
and you see that their project is
failing or you see that their people are
revolting against them or you see that
they're missing deadline after deadline
they know that too and then what you're
doing is you're coming to them basically
as like a concerned friend that really
wants to help them win and and pointing
out some of these obvious failures that
they might not be you know aware of and
you still got to be gentle about this
mm-hmm but when you come to them you can
come to them as a friend as a as a
person that really wants them to win you
can come out out of there looking like
the good guy trying to help them get
there their self back on track
so those are some of the some of the
basic strategies and I used to help
people do a little course correction if
people need a little criticism so that
they can improve their game for
themselves for the team
etc people are people aren't big blind
people don't like criticism yeah here to
tell you yeah they like praise you know
how and you know the other side of this
coin if you're a person which you are
and you don't like Christon which you
don't if you can open your mind to the
criticism man you're gonna be so you're
gonna get so much better about
everything that you do if you can just
listen to people about getting eco crazy
and thinking about this yep this list
you just listen to hide your head listen
to what they have to say they're trying
to help you yeah right
we assume that they're trying to help us
yeah listen to I don't know oh yeah are
there times they're not absolutely yeah
because that you're going with the
assumption that this person just trying
to cut me down well then that's not
gonna get you anywhere yeah but if you
if you make this something you know what
I'm gonna listen to what this person has
to say what's wrong with that yeah even
if it's an assumption and we're not
supposed to assume if I assume you know
what I'm gonna assume that echos giving
me criticism right now cuz he wants me
to do better and I'm gonna take them as
as face value as I can that he is trying
to help me get better no yeah and yeah
that's actually really correct if you
start at that point that's your default
right hey this criticism is to help now
I might look at your criticism and I
analyze it from a detached perspective
and I go I think actually echo is just
trying to drag me in the wrong direction
cuz he's jealous and I might get to that
point yeah and it'll be more lame or
obvious and it'll be way more if he if
you started at that other place but if
you're just default all he just wants to
try to look like he knows there he just
wants to you know make if you start
higher place to this yeah you can't even
kind of discern ooh you know if that
really is happening or not not the place
to be another place
me next wish chuckle what's the best way
to combine striking and grappling with
self-defense in mind never heard you
mention MMA in this context only do
Jitsu with gloves on consequently how
the teams adapt MMA base training to
real situations what's your take on
Army's modern army combatives okay so a
few questions there how do you best
learn to combine striking and grappling
well what you do is you combine striking
grappling that's how you get go ahead
you put on the big gloves we used to
call it shoot boxing that was like a
block of training that we doing with
guys that were fighting MMA you put on
the big the the relatively big boxing
gloves and then you put you mix in
takedowns with them so that's great you
should do that you can do that with kids
too you can do that with kids where you
put the big boxing gloves on kids and
you have a shoot those double legs all
day long so when somebody takes a swing
at them they know how to set up they
know the timing they start to get
familiar with it because in a way that
well it take downs are easier in MMA
because the person is not solely
defending against a takedown they're
defending against punches they're
defending against kicks so they have to
be in a different stance and so that's
the way it works if you want to train to
get combined strike and grappling you
have to combine them together and you
know in the if I've only mentioned it
with jiu-jitsu it comes on man I've done
a ton of MMA sparring with fighters like
a ton with gloves with big gloves shoot
boxing little gloves everything and I
don't know why I haven't talked about it
much but yeah I've done a ton of it and
that's how I know like taking someone
down with that's trying to punch you is
easier mm-hmm
now it sucks when you get punched but it
is easier then going against someone
that's just trying to wrestle you and
has a different stance a lower stance
and all that so yeah that's how you do
it you put you put you put big gloves on
and then also you can do you can drill
with big gloves on where someone's
trying to punch you while they're in
your guard or while you're punching well
we'll use someone's trying to punch you
while they're mounted you can do that
with slaps - right like I mount you and
I'm just start slapping you because then
you realize if these were punches you'd
be in serious trouble
so yeah you can mix those things in and
mix them together
don't get hurt be careful but yeah you
can definitely mix them so now the next
question was how do the teams adapt to
MMA based training all the big concepts
are the same the big concepts are
exactly the same you're gonna have to
close the distance like you got someone
that's unarmed that you're gonna need
your control of well you got to close
the distance you got to take them down
you got to get control of them you got
to submit them or subdue them somehow
that that can happen you got to be able
to break away if somebody grabs you you
got to be able to break away you gotta
be able to get up off the ground there's
some large muscle movements that are
exactly the same
the striking parts are exactly the same
someone's you know you want to clear
some water or you want to punch someone
to get them did you know a little bit
dis disoriented before you get control
him yeah that's that's that's what
you're doing that's what that's what
boxing is you know and so those things
aren't there's so much of it that
overlaps that the adaption doesn't have
to be barely anything the adaption comes
in and we have to do some additional
training some additional concepts that
you're moving with gear on that you have
to be able to protect your weapons and
your weapon systems so you you know you
want to be aware of where your rifle is
where your pistol is where your knife is
so that people can't get a hold of it
mmm
weapons retention so that becomes part
of it the the fact that you're working
with another person usually a partner a
shooting buddy that's good you that's
gonna cover move for you so if I go to
take a guy down I got to be aware of
where my partner is in case that person
that I'm trying to take down gets the
upper hand or has a weapon that I didn't
see so that my partner can get a clear
shot so there are tactical things that
you do have to add in but the
fundamental concepts there's they're
they're so transferable they're so
transferable that it's it's it's like
you know I'm its Agia nogi right
it's Agia know you if someone is awesome
at ghee they're gonna be good at noogie
yeah and it will are there some concepts
that you need to learn yeah there's some
little things but there's an overlap is
huge baseball and softball right
if someone played college baseball and
now they're playing on their local
restaurant softball team they're gonna
crush it right it's not the exact same
sport longboard surfing versus short
board surfing right if someone's a great
surfer on
shortboard they're gonna be decent on a
longboard they might they're not good
they might not win the world champ like
if someone's awesome noogie mmm and they
don't really train gee they're not gonna
win the world's but there'll be they'll
be damn good one of the things that I
used to well ok shooting shooting you
got combat shooting but then you just
have competitive target shoot right is
competitive target shooting the same as
combat shooting no there's no explosions
there's no movement or oftentimes I know
there's conferences where they do a
movement too and the more close it is
the better it's gonna be but if you're a
competitive rifle shooter and you and
then you do combat shooting it is
definitely what there's a ton of
crossover one of the things that I used
to talk about a lot when people would
question hey well MMA fighting isn't
pants not good for the SEAL Teams
because you don't have any gear on but
one of the examples that I used a lot
was guys that were really into
parachuting and you know when you when
you jump in the civilian world you don't
have a rucksack you don't have a weapon
you don't have night-vision goggles you
don't have any of that stuff and yet if
you have a thousand jumps as a civilian
with a slick rig on you're gonna be
infinitely better at the military
skydive with with the weapon and the
rucksack and the night vision and all
that you're gonna be infinitely better
it's the same exact thing are there some
little things that you can have to
figure out some details where that where
they don't completely overlap yes
absolutely so there you go so well I
guess when you train jiu-jitsu wrestling
boxing Muay Thai there if you're in the
military you know you also have to make
sure that you carve out time where you
think about the other components right
about be having gear on what that what
change is when you have your gear on how
to protect your weapons all that stuff
that I talked about about about working
with other people about the tactical
situations that you're in because
there's may be some tactical situations
that you're in if you're not thinking
straight
you're gonna have a problem you ever you
ever had somebody that goes would you to
smell good for self-defense
what do you do pull guard in the street
it's like no you're never gonna pull
guard in the street or you shouldn't as
if pulling garden is like the only yeah
but here's the bit well the fact is if
someone takes you down in the street and
you don't know the garden water you
gonna do you're gonna get your face
smashed yeah so you got to cover both
angles but there's so much overlap that
if you get good and apt the fundamentals
of MMA you will be really good at the
what you need to know with the
additional concepts on military tactical
types type situations as far as modern
army combatives it's a great solid front
of foundational program and created by
some great great martial artists that
were in ground floor I think Matt Larsen
is the guy that that kind of is the
grandfather of her father if I don't
know if he's old enough to be
grandfather he might even be my heat so
I don't know it's not it man
but yeah I mean he put together great
system and it's a great fundamental
system is could someone pick apart some
aspect to the army computer you could
yeah let me look at the whole system
it's a great solid system get people
start out on so props yeah I mean any
system you can kind of say that for yeah
yeah yeah yeah you go and well that's
why it's important to that's why I said
foundational system right because it's a
great foundational system because once
you learned it you don't you don't learn
the army combat the modern army
combatives and say okay good now you
don't need to train anymore that's not
the right answer the right answer is you
have a good foundation now keep building
on it yeah that's the answer
yeah I remember used to train for MMA
and pankration that train for a while
and the sparring element of it you know
there's three feet cuz there's it you
know even if you're training MMA you're
gonna train striking one day and maybe
even specialize striking stuff one day
and then you know wrestling and
grappling and jujitsu one day but you
have MMA sparring which is a full MMA
fight with big gloves and you know may
or may not have shame pads or whatever
but it's essentially MMA fight and that
is 100% incorporating grappling and
striking and take that's everything you
know so it's kind of like one of those
things where you get to train to fill in
those gaps between ok one moment I'm
striking one moment I'm grappling and
the strikes while you're graphically you
know and there's and there's some
there's some inconsistencies because if
you were striking with big gloves then
you
can't grab someone's hands the way you
would with the little gloves on but you
like you said what it does is it fills
in the gaps yeah so yeah and that's what
the Train that training is for so like
you know if you're you know if you'd
like to play guard or you have a slit
game from guard or whatever if you train
like an MMA training or training with
strikes and stuff like that it'll really
expose where you're in danger in a real
fight because that guys get it you know
like it's gonna punch you in the face
down a lot so it's a faster paced thing
so it just builds your awareness of it
so I remember that that even when I just
go back to regular digits or whatever
it's like man I feel super aware of it
like almost like your anticipate okay I
can't get punch from actually think
about that all the time yeah always
think like I'll be rolling with Taylor
yeah and because Taylor isn't like Andy
I don't think about it as much because
Andy's more of a jujitsu fighter but you
know Taylor he's an MMA fighter and so
if he's on top of me for all-round like
he's in my top half guard yeah and when
we get down I'll be like I'm glad that
wasn't MMA because you would have
pulverized my head yeah you know and now
do some gaps open up when people start
punching yeah they do is there an
opportunity the other is but you're
gonna take some shots yeah well and then
at the end of the day all that is part
of it you know so it's like with your if
you're okay so here's the scenario I
find myself in where the guy I'm going
to get this a way better striker than me
like way more experience and just better
a lot my Jiu Jitsu is way better so it's
like to get this guy to the ground so if
we don't when we train this it I get
that practice to be okay I'm gonna use
this guy's striking to like get around
them or something like that I'm not
gonna like stand here and try to
strictly beat up this training session
but you do have to stand there long
enough to get them to think to get them
to forget about you taking them down
yeah fully that's what I always and you
see that at MMA fights too right you
can't just go in there and start
shooting on the guy cuz they know that
you're gonna try and take them down yes
they know their ground game is worse and
so they're gonna defend that takedown
exactly right and then I'm thinking
about you got to get them thinking about
that knockout and we're gonna knock you
out and sometimes it takes two minutes
sometimes it takes three minutes
sometimes it takes a round and a half
before you take your first shot yeah and
and really to be real with you it's
that's what this training is for so in
the beginning you might not even be able
to take that guy down because you look
all I know this guy he's that Jiu Jitsu
guy now he's gonna
training with us you drank me down and
he's just gonna beat you up from the
outside and actually yeah what he'll do
is he won't even beat you up
he won't even commit to his punches
because he doesn't want to overstep and
and give you any advantage on your
takedown yeah so he'll just sounded like
you said Stanley outside attacking you
in yeah and I say that because that's
kind of what happened to me so I'd go in
and then of course they just stay away
or sprawl cuz they know it's coming kind
of thing and then you know as you reset
from the straw sprawl he but one to cut
on on the separation no big deal one two
yeah just all round yeah you know I'm
saying them I'm saying it's funny
because when you say you know you take a
one two is you're getting away but
though that punch is big boys they stay
boy right yeah but after a while that's
what I'm saying you get that training
just through the time I know how this is
now okay it's not like jujitsu where I
can kind of you know just go and lock up
and if I don't get to take on pull guard
kind of thing these guys they're not
trying to grapple with you they're
trying to stand back on you get that
training you know so when you wind up
you know being able to take them down
all this stuff you can like you'll have
just way more fit and advantage because
you're aware of all these different
elements that you may you might not get
in just you Jitsu class you might get
them but you probably probably don't you
get a guy who always wants to stand up
right and jiu-jitsu class try roll with
a guy in jujitsu just straight Jiu Jitsu
who only wants to stand up who just
would rather die than be in the bottom
Hill stat it's so annoying sodon't it's
challenging I don't think you need to
learn to contend with kar there are
tactics that you can use as the guy on
top to keep them down they're exactly
right and you get MMA guys especially if
you're better than them at like the
jujitsu element of it that's what
they're gonna do so the absolute
reigning you're gonna get no Chuck
chuckle as a leader of a team or
business has decided to okay as a leader
of a team our business has decided to
terminate one of my people I disagree
with their logic but I'm not in a
position to change the decision what
should I do to retain my influence to
support the rest of my team yet not
compromise my values that's a good
question that's a solid question that's
a tough question it's a little bit
tricky without the details of the
situation but you know I
I wonder what kind of relationship that
the person that asks a question I wonder
what kind of relationship you have with
the senior leadership that makes those
decisions because you've got to remember
that our goal is to always have the
relationships up the chain of command so
that you can influence those decisions
and if you have that kind of
relationship then you can find out why
that decision got made and there might
be things that you didn't know about
some kind of strategic outcome that the
decision you know has had an alpaca and
impact on right so if you didn't know it
but this guy had some kind of criminal
situation going on and you didn't know
it then they can't talk about it because
it's in legal case okay if you don't
know don't speculate just go and ask and
then you can take whatever those reasons
aren't you can articulate them you know
down the chain of command and again you
want to you want to ask this question in
a smart way you know say why did Bill
get fired hey why do bill get fired no
you said hey you know from my
perspective it seemed like Bill was
doing a good job I want to kind of
understand what you were seeing so that
I can lead people better and there's
anything that I can make up for I want
to make sure I'm leading it you know
like all those things you want to you
want to help their ego and make them
feel good and make them feel like you're
on board of the program and not make
them feel like you're going there
questioning their call because that's
just an attack on their ego so this is
all these things it's a basic things
right the fun of us he called it basic
pieces the fundamental things right this
is the this is the way it is standard I
should just say standard that's what I
should say standard stuff you you're
trying to build a relationship you don't
want to go in but your head up against
their ego then they get more defensive
and next they know they're gonna fire
another one of your guys on your team
just to prove a point you can get
yourself you can dig yourself that hole
but if you make your goal hey I'm gonna
build a relationship with my boss that's
what you are trying to do now if you
find out why then you can articulate
that to the rest of the team and and the
way that you maintain your values is by
maintaining your values okay so just
because there's a situation that our
decision that gets made that you don't
agree with doesn't mean that you
compromised your values like your boss
can make a decision and that does that
that you don't agree with that doesn't
mean that your values are compromised
unless it's like an illegal or it's an
immoral or it's an unethical
situation which by the way a firing
could be one of those things right the
guy could be firing because he wasn't
you know what wouldn't a he wouldn't
give me the the keys to the vehicle for
the weekend so I could use it on my
private time and I'm gonna fire him now
like that's unethical right there's a
problem there so now your values
definitely if you just remain silently
you're kind of compromising your values
so there are times when you may have to
stand up but bosses make decisions
that's what they do
and we do our best to influence them now
if they decide something we don't like
them yes we ask whine if we don't like
their explanation then we try and
explain our case we try and explain why
we thought bill should have been not
been fired now you're not always gonna
be right you're not always gonna be
right and let me tell you something else
don't argue about six and one-half dozen
the other bill might have been on the
fence and they decide you know what
we've had enough trouble with Bill we're
getting rid of them and maybe there's
valid reasons why bill should have said
but it's like it could have gone 6040
are you gonna put your reputation and
your relationship with your boss on the
line for over that little thing now
again I understand firing people is a
big deal it's not small it's not a
little thing especially you have a good
relationship he's on your team he's got
kids you know I think all these things
are there so what are you gonna do about
it
are you gonna break down and and
negatively impact your relationship with
your boss over this so that in the
future you have even less influence and
what happens when they go to fire Mike
and you haven't and all you did was go
hey why'd you do this is so stupid
they're gonna fire my can they're not
gonna listen to a damn thing you said
you want to build a relationship with
you can you can explain what your
viewpoint us and what you would have
done now this is like doubt this is
talking to your team you can explain
what your viewpoint was and what you
would have done but you also if you
don't want to you don't want to you want
to be gentle right as long as you
explain if you explain that hey I would
have done something different and you
you also explained that the boss it was
a tough decision and the boss made the
call and the best thing that we can do
as a team is support the boss so we can
garner
more influence over these situations in
the future that's good and you know what
one of the best things you could do here
with your team is you can even explain
that it's your fault the decision got
made right you say look I haven't built
a good enough relationship with the boss
that's why you fired bill I'm working on
it I'm gonna do it better we're gonna
give him the support that he needs so we
can stop this thing from happening from
happening in the future
so you don't want to throw your boss
under the bus it's much much better to
take ownership of it
all day all day if you throw your boss
under the bus and you create an
antagonistic relationship it's bad for
you it's bad for your boss and it's bad
for your team it's bad for your whole
organization I get it and there's a
dichotomy here because if your boss
totally fired someone with not good
reason and it was a great guy and if you
just jump on board of the boss you're
gonna look weak so do you have to
balance that yes you have to be honest
with your people you have to explain
what's going on that's why I think
taking ownership is one of the best
things to do your boss does something
that's totally out of line hey look
here's what the boss did this is my
fault and here's what I'm gonna do to
fix I'm gonna build a better
relationship I'm gonna get more
influence that's what I need to do I
obviously let you guys down I'm not
gonna let it happen again
that brings your team closer to you
rather than saying hey the boss was boss
an idiot he doesn't get it
your guy here people don't actually even
respect that by the way they don't
actually even respect that yeah I'm not
saying they say hey that's a boss's
decision and that's you know what we
just support the boss I'm not saying
that it's a dichotomy it's a balance
that you have to you have to carefully
walk compromise compromise on decisions
and directions and plants doesn't hurt
you know he's talking about compromising
it's like compromises okay
that's what it is compromises okay again
as long as you're not compromising your
personal values your ethics but
compromising about a decision that's the
way the world works don't let your ego
get into it don't let your ego so
keep building keep building
relationships take ownership of the
decisions and support the team keep
building relationships not just up the
chain of command but down so that you
can bring it all together
next question go question frogman do you
think it's always a bad thing to be
thought of as slightly unapproachable as
the leader yeah so this is another
question about the dichotomy of
leadership is another question about
balance and it's strangely worded
question by the way from this this
Scotsman who I know it's because he uses
the question all uses the word always
and usually always is always and never
right when you use those they usually
don't hold up it always a bad thing yeah
but then he kind of he kind of softens
the always by saying slightly on a part
also so we give him a fairly low grade
on this question but luckily the the
concept of the question we gave him a
high grade which is is it is it is it
should you be unapproachable slightly
unapproachable
should you be that's the real question
should you be slightly unapproachable as
a leader well there's this is this is a
question about dichotomy the question is
about balance do you want to have people
approach you about every little problem
ratio as a boss do you wanna have that
happen no you don't know right do you
want to be the easy button where you
have to answer every single question and
make every decision if you're too
approachable that's where you're gonna
find yourself now at the same time at
the other end of the spectrum do you
want your team to never approach you
ever because you're unapproachable yeah
no you don't want that do you want them
to to be scared or intimidated from
giving you good honest feedback or good
suggestions about the way you're doing
things do you not want that to happen
because you're too unapproachable of
course not
so those are the dichotomies you can be
too too approachable and be the easy
button or you can be too aloof and too
distant and too unapproachable that you
don't even know what's happening on
lines and you can even put from them the
extremes are bad and so what you want to
do is you want to balance those two
dichotomies be in the middle be
approachable but not overly approachable
mm-hm and you'll be good pretty
straightforward I think we got time for
one more talk on what do you do when
you're broke in what do I do
when I'm broken when I'm broken I relish
it that's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
use it because if I'm broken then I just
found my limitations and until I know
what my limitations are how can i push
them how can I get better but once once
I see it once I feel it once I see where
I was broken then I can attack that
weakness I can fill in that gap I can
reinforce that breach if you break it
means it's time to fortify your will to
make it stronger then look there's
there's all kinds of different ways to
break you can break physically you can
break mentally you can break your heart
you can break your spirit and none of
those are fun and all of those are gonna
leave a mark
but the mark that they leave can be the
mark of victory or it can be the mark of
defeat because every time you break in
in every way that you break while it's a
chance it's definitely a chance for you
to give up and for you to just to fall
apart but there's also opportunity
there's opportunity to get stronger and
get smarter and get faster and get
tougher and get more stable and get more
resilient and get better when you break
you have the opportunity to show the
world the whole world what you are
really made of so so if you break if if
you break the fight isn't over in fact
if you break the fight is just beginning
and as you crawl up and out of that
dismal and wretched place covered and
you're covered in blood and sweat and
dirt and filth as you rise above what
you were and as you take the form of of
who you are supposed to be
you will see that in the very act of
standing up in the very act of fighting
on you will become and you will remain
unbroken and I think that's all I've got
for tonight so
echo Charles speaking of getting
stronger and faster and tougher and
better sure better maybe you got some
ways we could you know support ourselves
with those goals yeah
facilitate getting better and stronger I
like it push the breaking point I'll
tell you that that'll push your breaking
point
especially the the joint warfare part
coming right in coming in hot okay so
start with the origin right origin
American made yeah
we're at the origin immersion camp right
now yes sorry that you're not here okay
up here in Maine or we're happy that you
aren't here or yeah if you're here we're
happy you're here yeah definitely
there's a lot of people in the game
there's a lot of people in the game a
lot of people heard us say on the
podcast come to the origin camp and
they're here and guess what yeah in
force it's awesome yeah every level
how many black belts are here dang I
don't know a lot yeah and how many white
belts are here oh yeah how many people
have never trained you to Allah a decent
number okay to get to put into context
this is the I think we had to do this
right or or we just do nonetheless this
is what we did we're breaking up yeah so
where everyone convenes in the morning
right for on the big mats and they're
like hey who hasn't had any experience
at all or you know under a however a
month or a mom yeah or something like
that go with Jocko guys over here to
this other mat yeah the other mat was
full it was full yeah so it's it's like
it's late the point is it's not just
like people who wanna just you know kid
after their jujitsu game and they've
been in it for you know years and years
and they want to camp out and dude it's
not that yeah
and it's a little there's a lot of
difference - I like that like yes like
yesterday the deco and I thought the top
the new jiu-jitsu people yeah
today I think was the deco and - I
stayed down with the the colored belts
right
I think there's I think there's probably
the same number of black belts here as
people that their first day ever
yeah on the mats was here yeah yeah I
think it's about the same number what
like 20 20 of each 20 people that have
never trained digits before and 20
people have their black belts in
jiu-jitsu there's like those two and
then there's everyone in between you
this guy I'm sucking this guy he's like
he goes yeah today is my second day okay
oh yeah right on where where you know
when was your first day where was he
goes oh yeah here yesterday I forgot I
came one day ft is gonna hear sweet
crazy is where we are right now yep more
of everyone to the factory yeah the car
engine factory in Farmington Maine saw
where everything is made yeah big time
so what do we have
jeez Rascar there's a new key you guys
were extra fired up about extra extra
fire Oh was that is that a deal thing
it's well you can't show anybody but we
do have a new guy coming yeah and we'll
say it's it's very awesome legit yeah
nonetheless bees origin the best keys
the best keys hands down everyone knows
they're ready it's like what do you call
this common knowledge anyway
made in America 100% made in America
also rash guards all kinds of jujitsu
stuff those shorts those new shorts they
came out with approve big time yeah yeah
they got some some sweat suits two
joggers shirts and whatnot oh good stuff
supplements yeah you know the
supplements these are supplements that
how do I pick what supplements I'm gonna
make it's supplements that I've taken
yeah and dial them in the protein the
Mulk
taste good is good no sugar
what's it got one carb two carbs
something like that yeah something like
that
just a little tasty
they're just but it's really late
yeah you were talking about doing
warfare at join warfare
we got krill oil all good we got
discipline you pre I saw a lot of people
drinking discipline like heading to the
maps a lot of people drinking that and
yeah man
someone said it was in that big cooler I
didn't go over there and check don't
make sense yeah it's it's so much we got
that that's origin main or Jemaine calm
you get all that
that's our company we're making all this
stuff we're to keep making stuff until
until we make everything that we use
that's their goal yeah yeah and I should
the joint stuff man that the joint stuff
one is the one that it's like it every
day go to in my case it that's month to
where I'm everyday I'm pounding welcome
on the mulcher yes he said and and you
you surprised me earlier because I asked
you because you always say you're on the
milk train fully fully or you say you're
fully on the milk train usually you say
yeah usually you say you're on the milk
train fully just Sirhan and I asked you
could someone be partially on the milk
train and you said that that was in fact
possible I don't know how that's
possible but well you know how many more
how many milk a day certifies you as
being on the mocha train at least one a
day okay that's pretty that's that's
doable this mother that's not crazy but
if you're pounding monkey everyday
that's the monk train regardless but
mostly okay that's why mocha day is
fully on the mock trip that's like two
sometimes three yeah yeah imagine so
basically with every meal two scoops not
to hit two situations to me two scoops
is minutes one one that's one drink see
that's the thing is I've got this new
thing where I do these little headers
yeah didn't feel wrong we're hanging out
we talked about hit but he doesn't even
know about more I gotta send him some
milk you know so he can have a hitter I
hate her is one scoop in one scoop it
doesn't that's the thing is it doesn't
make because when I have a double shot
of milk I'm full right there's no
there's no room you know I'm not and
animals could take some time to digest
right that's a meal basically you just
say a steak a big one
that's how I feel yeah well now I can if
I have a one scoop hater just get one of
those hit ah then you can go yeah you
can keep ooh you can workout like 45
minutes later you can be in the gym yeah
okay on the mat that makes sense
actually now that I'm thinking about it
I don't take it like I'll do it for
every time like if I workout that I'll
eat after I workout yeah well most of
the time but okay so here's the
situation got home the other day woke up
in a crappy hotel somewhere early in the
morning early morning flight woke up
didn't work out at the hotel early
morning cuz I knew I was heading back to
my house where I could be in my home gym
so waited got home was hungry did a
hitter yeah because I was hung cuz the
neck the night before guess what didn't
eat why didn't eat was working so got
home I was I was like pant got home
wanted to want to eat something but
still wanted to work out before lunch
hitter okay yeah make sense yeah and
then BOOM still got work to do you know
I think that's what come on something
wasn't that hungry yeah just sort of fit
it in your whole thing yeah but yeah and
then consider the joint warfarin the
krill oil boom everyday joints squared
away yeah I didn't mean for that to run
but it does all good skills also good
way to support we have a store
technically Jocko has a store I helped
make it so we have a store affirmative
either way it's called chocolate store
you know rash guards are available rash
guards under Agee yes or no what's your
opinion well yeah yeah whatever you like
first of all some people mandate it oh
there's some schools that it is
mandatory you will wear a rash guard
under your ghee okay there are some
schools where you're not allowed to are
you la can you wear I'm gonna turn some
tournaments you're allowed to some
tournaments are not allowed to there's
some rules out there so find that out
and you can get one of these rash guards
that say something on I'm like good
after it or something like that you know
and yeah rash guards t-shirts you can
get hats
yeah good to have done there yeah flex
fit if you're into it okay jock was not
into flex fit yeah
I dig it did we figure out the numbers
yet figure out what's more popular no
which one was the one do people like
more we don't know yet
I don't know I remember the fan never
the flex fit phase but I think we're out
of it man I think we're back to I think
everyone in Americans back to truckers
Oh like that's kind of what we're doing
now I think that's what America I think
America's on board with chuckle I could
be wrong role because we know my fashion
sense is completely in the dough not
exist yeah yeah you're a so yeah I don't
know I'll find out and report back but
if you want a shirt you know these
shirts then the ones that say discipline
equals freedom boom that's where you can
get them chocolate or also look one with
Jacques head on it this is good more
than a few people have said hey man I
really like you know your stuff but I'm
not willing to share with your giant
head on it yes not for everybody
everyone for everybody somebody said hey
is there a shirt with your head on it to
me oh and it reminded me a while yes it
is is one day uncle designed being sure
actually yeah so that's that's one
little factoid what's a factoid small
fast small factor that many people don't
know a lot of the designs that we're
part of like you know Ashlin front and
you know some of these designs chocolate
job you made the designs you didn't make
the official one but you were with your
left hand or whatever like through the
design concept is mine yeah the concept
is mine but you physically drew it it's
not like you said hey I wanted to do
this you know you like drew it out a
picture's worth a thousand words I'm not
writing you a thousand word paragraph
with that echelon front signal Oh what's
a choco podcast thing is gonna look like
or what the jockle white tea whatever
gonna draw it boom there it is do it
yeah so you're technically a designer
see the ideas
yeah people don't know that now they do
and the last it's called jackal story
calm yeah man get something represent
big-time big-time also subscribe to the
podcast if you haven't already on iTunes
and stitcher if you have Android that's
that's the big one for Android yes I
think they have iTunes for Android I
don't know either way whatever you use
to stream podcasts subscribe if you
haven't already don't forget about the
warrior kid podcast working on it's
we've got 16 out right now I think maybe
17 out right now but anyway it's more
common on that and a lot of the good
feedback I'm getting is that the kids
want to listen to him over and over and
over again which is kind of cool hmm so
I'll make more so kids can listen to
more of them and there's stuff in there
it's uncle Jake answering questions you
might think it's like questions up for
little tiny kids that you don't get
anything out of I think that's just
talking to some people I can't uh
chuckle this one one girl and she was
saying yeah she's like I'm totally into
the warrior kid podcast yeah come on ma
number 10 right now it's really good
itself see if those questions are for
everybody I'm like a right on this oh
yeah Uncle Jake has a little something
to teach everybody you know that's the
way it is also youtube we got YouTube
YouTube channel if you want to see
echoes legit videos we also oh the
videos we spoke of so we're getting we
need to get those done maybe we get back
to San Diego
yeah the two like yeah was it
life-changing but they were too
instructional life videos yeah came out
tips yeah yeah that's that's much more
appropriate that's good so you can also
see echoes legit videos enhanced
enhanced videos - sure yeah work also on
it on it dot-com / joke oh by the way so
you can get good workout gear legit work
up here I'm gonna vary up your workouts
also they have a lot of cool other stuff
there's this tri-blend peanut butter
it's but it's not peanut butter it's a
peanut butter almond butter and I think
cashew so it's like an enhanced peanut
butter
scenario that's what you use it for it's
good anyway they got a lot of cool stuff
on there like
that like warrior bars and whatnot yeah
we're bars can be it's like a beef jerky
but not jerky this is like a you know
way look at it's good super dense in
like protein and nutrient scenario
anyway on it calm /jo good spot don't
forget we got the psychological a
psychological warfare album that you can
get that has discussions tracks if you
will about how to overcome some moments
of weakness that you might hit and we
are working on the next one we're not
quite there yet so we're working on it
but yeah psychological warfare it's you
can get that anywhere iTunes Google Play
whatever mp3 platforms are out there
yeah you get him also
Jaco white tea yes the phenomenon yeah
it's funny like I know and people know
already I know I never really was into
tea actually even when the the but when
he called the dry to dry him I was like
cool cuz I was ping you know I'm on the
bus you were just you were just playing
you're just going along with it but you
know a game the here's the thing though
I was wrong with it I was giving I was
like a booty call go back and listen to
those podcasts and see if you were
trying to act like you're in the game
even them that we now know you weren't
well that's gonna make you whole your
whole deal suspect would know put it
this way I was in the game but it was
like because I was like on the hype
train you know how you know how like a
man everyone's doing this new thing and
you're like oh you just know that just
made you sound worse well hey man that's
the truth and everyone's gonna be so how
do we even know what you're saying right
now it's true about it
maybe it's alright maybe maybe now you
gotta find out for yourself that's the
thing so I think I might hate cool cool
but it kind of you don't kind of wore
off I don't drink tea that much but the
cans came out and what am i doing
pounding freaking teeth all day is that
height no because I wouldn't be pounding
it in every day I'm saying you wouldn't
be texting me for more boxes to be
delivered to your home yeah if you
weren't yeah and the actual T train yeah
we wouldn't be running out I'll tell you
that yeah that wouldn't be the case JP
JP sends me pictures of just jakka ytz
he asked me the other day how
how much what is there any amount of
jakka whitey that's not plain is like
fully on the train he might be one level
over the Train and into like the zone of
whatever addiction yeah so Jocko books
got some out there way the warrior kid
marks mission those two books man that's
one thing being up here how many how
many people have come up to me and said
my kids doing jiu-jitsu my kids doing
awesome school my kids doing pulps good
thank you so much for reading the
warrior kid books so if you want your
kid to work out to train hard to eat
right to study to do good in school hey
that sounds like there might be good
things yes get your book get away the
weird kid your kid is not gonna listen
to you as much as they're gonna listen
to an outside source make the outside
source something that you agree with
something that's tell them to work hard
study hard train hard way the warrior
kid and marks mission also got the
discipline equals freedom field manual I
like seeing how many people give this as
a gift to people you know just got this
as a gift I'll see that on social media
mhm mhm and then they get all stoked on
it so that's a little instruction manual
on how to get after it period if you
want the audio version it is not on
audible it is on iTunes Amazon music
Google Play as an album extreme
ownership that's the book of life and I
wrote combat leadership lessons that you
can apply to your business to your life
dichotomy of leadership listen to
podcast 138 we read a couple excerpts
from it that's coming out September 25th
if you want to get a copy of first a
dish order it now if you want third a
dish fourth the dish if you want to be
walking around with a big flag that says
hey I procrastinated I'm a
procrastinator I waited I didn't execute
I didn't prioritize and execute I didn't
keep things simple if you want to have
that flag you want to sport that flag
hold off don't order it get in the
fourth the dish and there's a dishes are
gonna go out quick because here's the
deal the the the
publishers that are conservative cirno
yeah yeah I know your first books your
first few books have sold well but you
know that's no guarantee for the next
one
they might just you know we probably
should only run this many and we don't
know you know just to see anyway we can
run more Fateh takes a little bit more
time for people to get them it's ok
they'll live like no actually they won't
they'll actually get a good time
so get that first a dish going make now
this is cool if we as a group order
enough now the everyone in that first
group will get first a dish because
they'll pour it more first editions
which is the goal that way more people
don't have to bear the shame and some
people say oh I you know I had first a
dish but I gave it away and now I have a
new one don't do that keep the first two
dish like when you somebody sent me the
British a dish of about face first a
dish British your dish it's a different
cover I'm about face so somebody sent me
from England
about face the book England copy British
one so I got that in my bookshelf mmm
that's different the one day I want to I
want to take pictures so I I like have
things that are the same like when I
like I have flip-flops on wear
flip-flops around
sure I have nine pairs all the same I
have a bell face I got 10 12 copies of
it just racked up cool I got my same
watch you mean these watches I got I
think I got six one of them might be
broken no a couple of them are broken
but I keep them for spare parts
what's in case he had a feature like I
know what kind of running shoes to I
have it's all the same workout shoes
they're my workout shoes memory shoes
are all the same
boom thee what about my workout clothing
we're all the same I never think about
it what about that shirt that victory
it's the same thing I got a lot of them
okay so what we could go in my house and
just like take a picture of watches
flip-flops sneakers short you my shorts
I wear the same damn shorts all the time
so we're just what is doing it yeah but
for sending me and I'm gonna send the
person that sent me the British a dish
ELISA send him some selling copies of
[Music]
some books of mine a on top of that get
a leadership consulting company me Lafe
Babb and JP Danelle Dave Burke Flynn
Cochran Mike Sorelli
we solve problems through leadership
that's what we do now if you want us to
come in as consultants and look at what
your situation is
and help you align your leadership go
national on front comm if you want one
of us to come and speak to your company
go to a tional on front comm that's what
you don't call speaking agency just go
to national on front comm we have the
muster real close to sold out I'm not
sure if it's sold out yet but muster
0:06 San Francisco October 17th and 18th
registered extreme ownership calm that's
the premier Leadership Conference in the
world sure I think actually no in the
universe sure because I don't think they
have any good leadership conferences on
Mars I think ours is better
yeah they do have one yeah it's probably
all hot cold so you hold I would muster
0 kg still get questions like hey I'm 58
years old and I have a bad knee would I
be able to do the muster if the answer
is yes the muster is anyone can do the
physical demands at the muster are very
very little if any if you don't you
don't have to come and do the morning
pts the morning physical training yeah
you can completely not come to that
you can beer more than welcome to come
and if you come you can just watch or
you could come or you could do the
minimum that you can do and that's fine
so there's no minimum physical standards
for participation at the muster if you
feel like you need to come come and also
on top of the muster we have another
event that we're doing for uniformed
personnel so military law enforcement
Border Patrol firefighters corrections
officers I've been adding that one in
paramedics other first responders roll
call zero zero on September 21st in
Dallas Texas it's a one-day leadership
seminar
or those folks in those dynamic
leadership environments registration is
gonna close so register you can also
register for that and the muster at
extreme ownership com
and of course we also now have EF
overwatch we are connecting SpecOps
veterans and the companies that want to
hire SpecOps veterans and combat
aviation combat aviation and spec ops
companies need leaders out there and we
are we have leaders that we're connected
with so we're trying to place them
that's EF overwatch comm and right now
we've got a awesome response from all of
our other brothers and sisters in the
military so we're working on something
right now to open up this to everyone
and until we see you at the muster or at
the roll call or maybe we won't even see
you until another year from now at the
immersion camp next time in Maine but
until then if you want to continue
hanging out with us virtually we are all
up on the interwebs on Instagram Twitter
and on Echo is that Echo Charles and I
am at Jocko willing and finally thanks
to the military people around the world
holding the line worldwide a thank you
for your service and in America police
law enforcement correctional officers
firefighters Border Patrol paramedics
other first responders thank you for
holding the line here at home and to
everyone else remember that life is not
easy but it's not supposed to be easy
life is a test and it's a hard test and
sometimes you might do great on that
test
and that's super but sometimes that test
doesn't go so well
then sometimes you might falter and
sometimes you might fail and sometimes
you might even break and when that
happens use it use it to make yourself
faster and stronger and smarter and
better and take a look at how and why
you broke us so that it does not happen
again identify your weaknesses come up
with a plan of attack and get after it
and until next time this is echo and
Jocko out